it's the dawn of a new day in south
africa and the letaba valley in the
northern province of limpopo shimmers in
the morning light the region is blessed
with plenty of sunshine and rain which
explains the lush forest tea plants and
fruits such as apples clementines
oranges considered the best in the
country it's this fertile landscape that
prompted the letaba company to set up
operations here 50 years ago it harvests
and processes citrus fruits without
polluting the environment as far as
possible the story begins here on the
fruit plantations the orange harvest is
in full swing right now the workers have
their hands full I enjoy picking I
enjoyed very well I don't have a problem
and I know the people most of the plume
I'm working with they enjoy the job very
wet so that's why I enjoy it I don't
care about the day of his job this is my
job this is what I want
even mush wanna and his co-workers work
hard eighty-five thousand tons of fruit
and up inlet Ava's factory each year
here they're sorted and prepared for
export or washed in Long tubs and
squeezed into juice letaba is one of the
largest citrus fruits exporters and
processors in southern Africa the
production process is sophisticated but
it's also highly energy intensive
previously the company consumed 8,000
tons of polluting hard coal each year to
power its operations now the firm's
management is opted for a greener
alternative sawdust since 2011 the
company has gradually been replacing
coal with sawdust this biomass fuel
already fires the large ovens used to
drive the fruit fields the Tabas CEO is
visibly proud of the switch to greener
energy from the hopper it comes through
in a screw from the screw it goes down
into the oven that year below us and
from the oven it goes into the dryer the
company emissions does not exist with
with the burning of the sawdust order or
the woodchips as it does with their with
their coal that we've to be fooled
sawdust is considered a valuable carbon
neutral biomass the way it works is easy
it's 800 degrees Celsius inside the oven
the sawdust burns like kindling the tons
of wet fruit peels discarded during
production are sliced and put in a
drying drum the hot air from the oven
sucks out the moisture from the peels
what's left is high-quality animal feed
it's a perfect form of recycling the
fruit remains are simply absorbed back
into nature and that's where the sawdust
comes from to just 20 kilometers away
from the factory huge forests on the
slopes are home to pine and eucalyptus
to fast growing tree species
it's no wonder then that forestry is
booming in the region here in the
mountains trees are constantly being
felled up to 300 a day at this spot
alone
below in the lumber mills on the main
road the trees are used to make pallets
for industrial use each cut generates
wood shavings what begins as a small
pile soon turns into a gigantic organic
waste mountain the lumber mills are more
than happy to turn their waste over to
the de taba company I mean if they can
use this stuff to the advantage it's
much better than for me just to leave
the stuff lying around yeah so no it's
under seeing if they can help me to keep
my place of it if we can help the
environment in any way that we can then
it's hundred percent so it's a win-win
situation both for the citrus maker and
the lumber mills and even transporting
the sawdust brings tangible benefits to
this man truck driver go to enjoy a casa
he began delivering the biomass from the
lumber mills to the top a year ago and
now he has a steady job I felt very
lucky when I got the new job in my old
job I sometimes had to drive loads as
far away as Johannesburg now I can work
here in the region close to my family
that's really nice
goulburn yah a casa sometimes drives two
or three sawdust truckloads to the
factory each day and that's expected to
increase in future because letaba wants
to replace its coal-fired boilers for
juice production with biomass fired once
the steam generated here and used in
juice pasteurization would also be an
organic by-product in the coming years
the tava wants to save 100,000 tons of
carbon emissions to capture that amount
we'd have to plant 8 million trees but
not everyone has benefited from the
tabas green initiatives hundreds of
workers many of them seasonal hands and
their families live in housing provided
by the company rundown Hut's donít Bilal
a key for instance lives with his wife
and this cramped home he's angry about
the conditions the house is not good it
doesn't have proper sanitation we're
really suffering the company doesn't
give back anything to us they don't give
us anything we don't benefit at all I
really like where it is the right Trish
Agassi but the company at least seems to
have accepted that it urgently needs to
improve conditions for its workers
former trust and a portion of the carbon
credit income will go into that trust
and our employees will directly benefit
in terms of education and housing
letaba seems to be trying to protect the
climate as well as bring about social
change and if that brings benefits for
the workers then the company's green
project would be a real success story